I'm so excited for today's video where
I'm gonna share with you 20 ways to save
money with minimalism never mind my
chickens in the background hello
everyone welcome to gessie TV where you
can find weekly videos on minimalism and
healthy living to help you live a
simpler happier life
number one cut cable I'm kind of curious
do you still have cable or not let me
know in the comments this is very common
for most people to not have cable
anymore but if you don't then what you
can also do is cut out movie and show
subscriptions that is of course if you
feel like you can survive without them
number 2 remove credit cards from stores
that you frequently shop at for me for
example I used to have my credit card
saved onto a target account which was
too easy for me to just go in there
browsing and end up with things in my
cart that I could just easily click and
buy by removing saved cards from
accounts such as Amazon for example
you'll make yourself have to do one
extra step in order to buy an item you
have to actually get out of your sofa
pull out your wallet type in those
credit card numbers and then purchase
the item for some people these extra
steps are enough to make them realize
that they really didn't need the item at
all number three
cancel any unnecessary subscriptions for
me I cancelled my gym membership because
I realized I can workout at home I don't
need to pay for this I also canceled my
Pandora subscription because while ads
are annoying
it's not necessary to pay for it so take
a look at what subscriptions you're
paying for that you could possibly go
without for example magazines number for
DIY DIY DIY
if you can't live without that frappe
with the whipped cream and the drizzle
on the top that cost you like six
dollars find a way to make it yourself
you will save so much money in the long
run if you make it yourself and it can
be kind of a fun experience as well we
live in an era where we're so fortunate
to have all the information that we
could possibly want at our fingertips
need something done around your house
look it up as well
number five stop buying bottled water
buy a reusable cup and a filter and you
will save so much money in the long run
number six
cut out sodas and carbonated beverages
they're just an extra expense and
they're not any better for your health
and for extra savings cut out pastries
and chips as well because these have no
nutritional value and they're really
just costing you more money
number seven find ways to save on
utility bills for example use cold water
when you can if you have a clothesline
hang dry clothes outside and change the
thermostat just a few degrees any small
change you can make will help number
eight get only the service you need for
phone and Internet my husband and I
didn't realize that we were paying $10 a
month to use our internet providers
Wi-Fi router when we had our own wit
also didn't realize that we were paying
for extra gigabytes on our phone service
that we weren't actually using so look
at what you're actually using a needing
and cut off any extra number nine don't
shop for fun I used to find shopping as
a hobby and I tried to instead find new
hobbies that were more productive and
can possibly actually take blending
number ten quit buying something every
time you go to a gas station or a store
that's what never really applied to me
but I know a lot of people that every
time they go to a store it's almost like
they have to treat themselves as a
reward for even going to the store they
buy something whether it's a knick-knack
a candy bar a drink all of these things
they add up and no your kids don't need
a toy or food every single time you go
to a store that's only training them to
do the exact same thing in the future
number eleven may not apply to you but
don't buy clothes that require steaming
or dry cleaning because who really wants
to bother with that kind of similarly
number twelve don't buy any items that
require you to make any extra expenses
for example my husband and I had
wireless cameras where we were
continuously buying disposable batteries
because we didn't realize all this time
that there was a rechargeable option and
on the note of rechargeable anything
that is disposable try to find a
reusable option for while yes you do
have to spend money upfront
most of the time you will save so much
money in the long run so things like
menstrual cup for me that has saved me
so much money in pads and tampons
napkins you can use a cloth napkin for
razors you can use a safety razor or a
rechargeable electric razor there the
the list is infinite really so look for
all the things around your house that
are disposable and try to find a
reusable option
number fourteen
don't buy personal care items such as
creams ointments toothpaste all that
sort of stuff you'd be surprised how
much of personal care items you can make
it home very cheaply with non-toxic
ingredients for example my toothpaste is
just coconut oil peppermint essential
oil and baking soda my shampoo is just
honey
aloe vera castile soap and water and my
lotion is beeswax balm and coconut oil
there's so many things out there like
face washes and scrubs that you don't
really need just an extra expense find a
natural way to make them you will save
so much money number fifteen give gifts
that hold more value but with less
expense so this goes along with what we
already mentioned with DIYs like making
a handmade cake or a pastry for a
handmade scrub but for couples it can
also be really helpful to agree to do
something together instead of buying
each other a gift before we continue I
want to know what is it your favorite
gift to give well let me know in the
comments number sixteen grow your own
food if you can we just moved into our
house so our garden is a bit small but
we already have things like squash
tomatoes and fresh herbs to help you get
started you can watch my video on how to
replant veggies from food scraps I will
include the link in the description
number 17
you knew this one was coming cook your
own food I hear you we're both full-time
working parents so oftentimes the last
thing that we want to do is cook but
what's helped us tremendously is meal
prepping and this does not have to be
fancy look up some simple recipes that
can become your go-to easy to make like
for example a chili throw everything in
a crock pot and done
when we look up all of these fancy
recipes with a bunch of ingredients we
are just overwhelming ourselves and it's
more likely that we're not gonna do it
number 18 okay hear me out on this one
buy better quality I can't tell you the
number of times we try to save money by
buying a cheaper tool and it ended up
either breaking very quickly or doing a
poor job sometimes buying better quality
can save you money in the long run and
especially with business it can be a
much better investment number 19 borrow
or rent or possible despite common
thinking you don't have to own
everything that you use for example my
husband rented his tux when we got
married and I borrowed serving platters
for parties so the next time that you
need something that you likely won't use
again or very frequently look at this as
an option and lastly number 20 find ways
to make your purchases and investment
for example when we got married I was
not about to hire a photographer to pay
this person for a one-time service some
people really value professional photos
but for me it was about an investment
why pay somebody for a one-time expense
when I could buy a camera save some
money and use it for years to come
another example that's personal to us is
my husband has a lot of tools which yes
they are expensive but he's been able to
use them to build furniture and do jobs
that has brought us back more money so
for you let's say you're buying a sewing
machine
you can make things and then sell them
so that sewing machine ends up paying
for itself you're the expert on what
your talent is select that but your
inspiration if you've stuck with me
until the end I appreciate it so much
please don't forget to Like and
subscribe so you won't miss out on
videos like these bye for now
[Music]